in Marvel Studios black panther wakanda
forever we get to visit the underwater
nation of talocon and to find out how
those incredible scenes were filmed I'm
talking to visual effects supervisor
Jeffrey Baum and Jeff how are you I'm
very well thanks Tim thanks for having
me I appreciate it great to have you now
I heard that for the underwater scenes
in the film you actually shot underwater
now why did the team choose to take on
that challenge
one of the most important things in Ryan
coogler's storytelling uh is the
authenticity of where characters come
from and I think part of that here is
combining an underwater world with a
culture that we can all relate to
early on Ryan had made it clear that he
wanted to shoot as much as possible
underwater now there's logistical
challenges that come along with that
process for sure not just from the
technical side of equipment tanks and
all that stuff as well but also the
abilities of the talent as well are the
performers comfortable with going
underwater not only are they comfortable
are they still able to perform
underwater is Ryan able to give
direction underwater
it was quite a challenge both due to the
physics of being underwater as well as
the visual aspects of Storytelling of
color and cameras underwater so it was a
big challenge to show strength movement
speed and all of those aspects
underwater while at the same time
staying true to MCU expectations if you
will the underwater performances are
Next Level how did the cast prepare we
often shot whenever possible an entire
scene underwater with our performers
after they've gone through rigorous
training with our stunt Department in
order to hold their breath for you know
multitude of minutes you know three four
five six minute long breath holds in a
tank for them to understand how to move
in water and the thought was even if we
did then transition into a drive for wet
World there would be a little bit of
muscle memory that was there for how
they had to move around
Chris Dennison our underwater Center
coordinator and our marine team and the
safety team did an amazing job of making
all of the performers feel comfortable
in water it was a you know multiple
week-long process of them just coming to
the tank hanging out at the surface
learning how to do their breath holds to
methodical but it also somewhat
meditational in a way where you need to
kind of really get your mind to relax
and be at ease as you hold your breath
so once the actors were ready to go how
did the production team go about
shooting the underwater scenes we did
the previous ahead of time to try to
figure out what the angles that Ryan
wanted and then we would try to take the
performers through each of their scenes
with a small set piece that was kind of
the center of the story and shoot that
and then that would be assembled and
then we would often then go back into a
drive for what world and then repeat the
same process knowing what it looked like
in the wet for wet world the performers
were aware of how they moved but the
drive for wet world then allowed both
Ryan and Autumn RDP to light it the way
they wanted so there was then the
ability for them to be able to interact
with the performers in a way that you
don't necessarily have underwater
when Neymar tells the telekineto that
they're going to go attack wakanda the
the drive for wet world was his throne
room and it was essentially a backing
that the art Department had built
knowing that we probably had to replace
a bunch of the uh of the set of costumes
Etc
so with so many visual complexities of
water how did the team apply visual
effects to create the underwater look of
these scenes we needed a base a baseline
for us to understand what water looked
like it's a place that you know some of
us are familiar with but in the depths
of the sea it's still a very unfamiliar
world for you know most of us we tried
to really again jump back to those early
tests and use those as our guide for
what water should be like in the what
the lighting of the CG World should be
like as well we started playing with how
light travels and what color is Autumn
light and Ryan like underwater so that
we could try to stay true again to the
reality of water the piece that I'm most
proud of is that we were able to include
as many characteristics of water as
possible so turbidity Marine snow that
affect Clarity so that it isn't crystal
clear but at the same time finding a
balance so that there is focus so that
as a viewer you're immersed in this
world and you understand you're
underwater without having to process it
too much but yet at the same same time
there is a clear point of focus for each
shot and that was something that Ryan
really wanted to stay true to of you
know color absorption and the the colors
that disappear underwater and I think
because we did that early on it allowed
Us in post to continue to sit with a
studio and the rest of the filmmakers to
kind of show what underwater truly
looked like and I think that that was
something that I believe for the most
part we were able to deliver on pretty
pretty successfully I'd say so you and
the team did an incredible job Jeff
thank you so much for chatting with us
and all of you at home make sure to
re-watch every moment of underwater
action in Marvel Studios black panther
wakanda forever coming soon exclusively
to Disney Plus
thank you